hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Peter Singer begins his essay the
biological basis of ethics with a short
passage by Henry Sidgwick representing
not just the utilitarian tradition but
but a lot of other traditions in
philosophy in making a certain set of
claims about duties or moral obligations
and he starts out saying this we should
all agree each of us is bound to show
kindness to his parents and spouse and
children and to other kinsmen in a less
degree and then he goes on from there to
describe other people who we have
similar obligations towards but notice
what is is really front and center here
as singer is going to point out parents
and children and spouse the very close
intimate family relationships and he
doesn't say that everybody has a great
family or that you know everybody is
going to get along with the people in
their family but he is saying there is a
recognized moral obligation based on a
sort of closeness that's really quite
arbitrary you could say that spouses
choose each other at least in some cases
although they often don't know precisely
who they're choosing until they get to
know them a little bit better but
children don't choose their parents and
quite frankly parents don't really
choose their children either because
children turn out very differently than
you that you ever expect so you know
there's this kind of strangeness to how
an arbitrary set of biological relations
granted with all sorts of cultural
status involved as well should be so
important in ethics and singer thinks
that actually this is not that
surprising at all so he begins by
talking about in the section kin
selection in human ethics and he says
the passage that I quoted is a
description of the principles Rek
regulating the duty of benevolence as
that Duty was generally understood at
that time it gives a graduated list of
those to whom we should be kind which
fits neatly here is where we gets a
singer's own perspective with
sociobiological theories what our
associate biological theories their
theories of ethics that say that our
biology plays an important role so that
selection operating on a number of
different levels both for the individual
and within groups is important favors
some sorts of behaviors disfavors others
leading to their replication and
reproduction and so on and so on and
it's it's sociobiological in that it
recognizes that with a human animal
there is an incredible amount of culture
involved as well so he goes on to point
out that in some ethics at least there
will be some where it's not the case and
in human behavior generally we have this
phenomenon that we call kin altruism
which is both the actual behavior of
favoring and showing benevolence towards
those who we are connected with
kinship ties however we conceived of
those however we mark and code those in
whatever society that we're in and also
there's a sense of aught a perceived
moral obligation there as well so it's
not purely descriptive it's also
prescriptive as well and you know we
could think about what our typical
instances of this looking after children
the idea that not always you know
honored by everybody if you produce
children you ought to take care of them
and you can find this in all sorts of
cultures and all sorts of ethical
theories and then also you know
supporting the family as a whole however
family is understood up and supporting
the members of the family so singer
talks about how in late Victorian
England there could be you know here we
go duties to parents alongside duties to
children and wives with duties to eight
brothers and sisters and then duties to
more distant relatives like cousins
things like that you know a great
example of this is when somebody strikes
it rich
and suddenly they have lots of cousins
some of whom may not actually be related
to them showing up holding out their
hand and saying where is my generosity
from you why are they doing that it's
not purely based on whatever I can get
out of somebody there's there's a sense
that there is some sort of obligation
there however it misplaced it might be
now singer says some you know
anthropologists and sociologists and
other social scientists would say that
this is not really biological this is
just cultural and he says that's not
really that big of a problem we can have
a flexible enough theory to say it's
probably got components of both every
society that we look at has kinship
structures they may arrange them
differently but they still have the same
and
even in our late modern society with
conceptions like say blended families or
you know widespread adoption and all
sorts of other things that that go on
we're still working with the same basic
ideas here in the same basic structure
of kin selection or kin altruism now
what is it to be altruistic it means to
be other center to focus on the good or
the needs of the other and perhaps to
make sacrifices of one's own interests
in the in the case that that it's
required now he goes on and he talks
about a few other important aspects of
this one is that we see that people tend
to favor kin over other people who from
an ethical perspective could be viewed
as having an equal claim on their
resources or their generosity what we
might call needy and deserving others so
he goes on and he he says think of our
reaction to news of a famine in Africa
those who care at all
may send a donation to one of the
agencies trying to help ten dollars or
fifty dollars even perhaps a hundred
dollars any more would be a rare act of
generosity by the standards of society
but those of us fortunate enough to live
in Western Europe North America
Australia or Japan regularly spend as
much or more on holidays new clothes or
presents for our children so if we cared
he says about the lives and welfare of
strangers in Africa as we do about our
own welfare and the ad of our children
why would we spend money on these
non-essential items for ourselves
instead of spending it to save lives we
could be buying mosquito nets or
important medicines or paying for a
school or a road or we could go down the
line with a whole series of ORS here why
don't we do that well because we tend to
you favor those who are related to us or
those who we perceive of as related to
us he goes on he says I have written and
lectured on the subject of overseas aid
arguing our affluence puts us under an
obligation to do much more than we're
doing to help people in real need at the
popular level here's where singer notes
there's there's a tendency here the most
frequent response is that we should look
after our own poor first among
philosophers sometimes replies are in a
more sophisticated manner I've been told
while we should do more to prevent
poverty we should do nothing
inconsistent here's where we get to the
kin altruism with our obligation to do
the best for our children and as singer
points out this obligation to do the
best for our children involves all sorts
of expenses that oftentimes are quite
high and rather arbitrary and don't seem
to get an awful lot of bang for the buck
in terms of human welfare what's an
example of this sending them to
expensive private schools a great
example of this is you look at our own
Congress our legislators you know they
they could be sending their kids to
schools in their districts especially
the ones who you know say maintain a
residence in the capital they don't then
certainly not to public schools they
tend to favor private schools right why
because you know private schools are
typically better off than public schools
they also tend to be very expensive or
he has another example here that you
might find a little bit funny buying
them 10 speed bicycles this is probably
a little bit dated they're buying them
gaming consoles the kids really need
gaming consoles or the latest fashion or
any of these things no not really but
people purchase these things for their
kids anyway instead of devoting those
resources even to the poor in their own
neighborhoods let alone the poor
elsewhere why is that the case
well he says that we have a preference
for our own which he says is
understandable in terms of our
evolutionary history we seek in altruism
in other animals and we it's not
surprising that we also see it in our
own and so he says that family ties are
based on what he calls an exclusive and
discriminating loyalty which sets the
members of one's family more or less
apart from others this is again what kin
altruism is and does he also brings up
proposals and even attempt to try to do
away with what we can call the
institution of the family the locus of
kin altruism he brings up Plato's
Republic and Plato's argument in the
Republic is so long as people are
thinking primarily in terms of their own
family they're not going to be a unified
society and the goal is to try to get
everybody to have the kind of affection
that we would have within a family and
the sort of altruism for the members of
our society what he's calling later
singer group altruism the goal is to do
that by eliminating the institution of
the family and it would be based on age
class so you just call everybody who's
older than you who is a male father and
everybody who is older than you mother
unless they're old enough to be
grandfather and grandmother perhaps
there's you know aunts and uncles or
things like that as well but we don't to
get into the weeds with that now Plato's
Republic was never put into practice at
least not successfully but he also talks
about the Israeli kibbutz 'm the idea
was put into practice there you would
have a collective and there would be
children born within it but then the
children are being mothered and fathered
being parented by a wide range of people
in there's an
hemp to try to minimize the amount of
family time and and separate households
and things like that and he noticed he
points out that this didn't really work
it says what for whatever reason once
the kibitz room became established in
the twin dangers of starvation and Arab
attack receded the ideal of unity proved
insufficient to maintain the original
intensity of communal feeling they have
survived but they had to come to terms
with the family couple spend more time
in their apartments often taking their
meals their children are with their
parents for much of their free time and
often sleep in the family apartment
rather than the children's house it's no
longer frowned upon for couples to sit
next to each other on all public
occasions children once again call their
parents mother and father and he brings
up other attempts to do this sort of
thing it's very difficult to eradicate
this family feeling now there are like
we pointed out a little bit earlier some
tensions between what's good for the
family and what's good for the larger
society so the last thing that Peter
Singer considers is this interesting
question well why do societies why do
they allow they tolerate and going
beyond that actually promote and praise
the family when it seems like family
loyalty could create people who are
going to be very good to their mothers
fathers children spouses siblings but
not so good to other people in society
so he says that the answer may lie not
just in the universality and strength of
family feeling but also in the benefits
to society as a whole that come from
families taking care of themselves
what are these benefits he says when
families see that children are fed kept
clean and sheltered so taking care of
children that the sicker nursed and the
elderly cared for
they are being led by what singers
calling bonds of natural affection or it
could be duty as well if they don't like
their family that much to do what would
otherwise fall upon the community itself
and either would not be done at all or
would require labor unmotivated by
natural impulses so the family because
of the way kin altruism works gets
things done that need to be done for a
functioning society and its members
granted there's going to be some people
are gonna fall through the cracks but
they can be brought into other families
as well they can be adopted they can be
taken care of and he says that in a
large modern community doing all these
sorts of things would require an
expensive and impersonal bureaucracy so
it may be more cost-effective and then
it goes on and says given the much
greater intensity of family feeling
compared with the degree of concern we
have for the welfare of strangers which
is not very much frankly ethical rules
which accept a degree of partiality
towards the interests of one's family
maybe the best means of promoting the
welfare of all families and thus of the
entire community
so kin altruism can be harnessed to
handle a lot of things that otherwise
would fall upon society to take care of
so it would have a sort of you know
pragmatic justification that's what
Peter Singer has to say about this
powerful impulse of kin altruism in this
this essay
you